i know it's early i know that lots can
change before 2024 but i think as of
right now i have got a candidate this
man is saying all the right things he's
seeing things clearly and he is more in
touch with the american people than the
entire ruling class and that man's name
is chet hanks
so um just checking in look i've been
kind of on the fence about this for a
while that's why i've never spoke on it
but with the amount of people that i
know recently that have gotten coveted
and with like the numbers rising i think
it's important for me to say like
i got the vaccine
i think everybody should i think it's
really important like that we all do
this just as like citizens as americans
we have to look out for each other and
get this under control guys so like i
suggest to all my followers you guys
make set an appointment and get the
vaccine first things psych
if it ain't broke don't fix it i never
had covert yay sticking me with that
[ __ ] needle it's the
[ __ ] flu
get over it okay if you're sick stay
inside i'm tired of having okay why are
we working around y'all if y'all uh if
you're in danger stay you're inside i'm
tired away tomorrow
brilliant articulate
so on the money i i love imagining that
that man is tom hanks's son he actually
is tom hanks's son there's much more to
dig into in chet hanks's political
philosophy
but for those who doubt that chet could
be president keep in mind that he now
has a much much better chance of
becoming president than andrew cuomo who
resigned yesterday in disgrace for all
of the wrong reasons but he's still gone
republicans can chalk it up as a win
but make no mistake the liberal
establishment still has all the power
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from osu formulator
who says if anyone asks me why i'm not
masked up i'ma tell them i'm still
celebrating obama's birthday that's a
great that's a great excuse it's hard to
argue with that one you know when you
want to feel protected i would strongly
recommend you go check out american home
shield no one likes to think about
household breakdowns but they happen
they happen way more often than you
would like they may have happened to me
actually just a couple of weeks ago
that's why it pays to have a plan from
american home shield to help cover the
costs to repair and replace things like
your ac or your fridge they have new
options to help you find just the right
coverage american home shield members
get more coverage options and fewer
exclusions from hvac systems and
plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
electronics coverage is available for an
unlimited number of eligible items such
as smart watches flat screen tvs and
more other options include roof leak
repair and pool and spa coverage
coverage is available no matter how old
your systems and appliances are just get
covered i'm i'm learning i've learned
this lesson the hard way in the past and
i'm learning to appreciate it now
be sure to get covered you don't want
one of these crazy repairs right now to
celebrate 50 years of providing
homeowners peace of mind you can take 50
bucks off their most comprehensive plans
ever go to ahs.com knowles to save 50
bucks
that is ahs.com knowles for fifty
dollars off any plan service fees
limitations in exclusion supplies you
plan for sales american home shield be
sure with the shield before we move on
from chet hanks we will there are other
things we have to get to but i i can't
tell you how much i enjoy not only the
fact that he's tom hanks's son but the
sorts of things he's saying so tom hanks
very famously very liberal actor friends
with obama very pro public health
bureaucracy
the list goes on and on and chet
is not so a chet also after he posted
his his rant about covid posted another
one after he left a barnes and noble
where they told him to pull up his mask
so i'm sick of this mash
flipping barnes and noble
buying books
check out my mask looks like a little
millimeter past my nostrils oh sure you
gotta have your mouth oh yeah my butt
not bad
slips down again sir you're mad oh okay
my bad
i'm like i go i go you're really on it
huh he goes uh yeah we are
okay
he's like
did you get the vaccine i'm like yeah
yeah for sure i got the vaccine psych
if it ain't broke don't fix it i've
never had kobe
so the crazy thing about these jet hanks
videos is that he has more credibility
than dr fauci because chet hanks uses
some salty language and he speaks in a
way that's kind of vulgar but
he hasn't gotten everything wrong about
kovit yeah i'm not making any listen
youtube
overlords i'm not making any comment on
the vaccines i'm just saying that what
we know from dr fauci
is that he has gotten things wrong and
wrong and wrong
again what we know from the liberal
establishment broadly is not not only
have they gotten things wrong but
they've actively misled us on multiple
occasions dr fauci admitted this when he
told us not to wear the masks and he
said we have to wear the mask and they
only told us not to wear the masks
because he wanted to save the mask for
his buddies
so chet hanks
i think representing something that we
saw come up with trump we've seen bubble
up a lot of times in american politics
which is
that people who don't use the jargon who
don't go along with the narrative who
don't do what all of the elite
institutions tell us to do those people
seem to have their finger on the pulse
of the people and of reality a lot
better and he may or may not become
president but andrew cuomo certainly
certainly is not looking likely to be
the next president lovegov has resigned
andrew cuomo
doesn't quite admit that he was wrong
doesn't actually say he was sorry for
anything but does say that he will
resign in the next two weeks
wasting energy on distractions
is the last thing that state government
should be doing
and i cannot be the cause of that
new york tough
means new york loving
and i love new york
and i love you
and everything i have ever done
has been motivated by that love we're
going to pause it right there just as a
a general rule in politics
if you are resigning over a sex scandal
you might want to minimize the love talk
the the love talk is not serving your
cause very well especially when andrew
cuomo does it in this
very bizarre sort of
bulldog-ish cuomo-esque way of i love
you i love i love my love made me love
so andrew cuomo goes on and on about the
love thing but then he finally gets to
the point namely he's out
and i would never want to be unhelpful
in any way
and i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside
and let government get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i work
for you
and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing for you
because as we say it's not about me
it's about we
it's not about me it's about we okay
i am
i would say 15 surprised that andrew
cuomo actually stepped down
i said it months and months ago when he
was first in trouble for this sex
scandal which was really just an excuse
to get him out after he had lost the
confidence of democrats from the covid
scandal which was just
one of the many scandals that has
plagued his administration and the cuomo
family has dominated new york politics
now for three four decades
andrew cuomo is one of the toughest
politicians out there this guy has
survived much worse than this and so the
reason that he is resigning now is not
because he winked at his secretary or
any of the other things that he's
accused of the reason he's resigning now
is because he is no longer any use to
the democrat establishment during the
lockdowns and the height of 2020 andrew
cuomo was a good foil for donald trump
he was this tough brash new yorker right
he was sort of the the anti-trump but
then now that trump is gone andrew cuomo
doesn't serve any purpose he's actually
a big liability
not just because of he got a little grab
happy with the staffers but because he
killed thousands of elderly new yorkers
and then covered it up from the federal
government when there was a doj
investigation so
andrew cuomo is out now we can chalk it
up as a win
but i think we would be foolish to
pretend as though this is a major
conservative victory this is the liberal
establishment moving the pieces around
on the table as it sees fit and if
andrew cuomo was still of any use to
them they would they would not have done
that by the way you're not going to hear
any sort of
apologies from the many many people who
lauded cuomo and and and praised him to
no end during 2020 and gave him emmys
and gave him their devotion and even
described themselves
as homosexuals like people such as
trevor noah the host of the daily show
the one governor who's crushing it the
most right now is andrew cuomo yes
thanks to his handling his approval
rating has soared to a seven year high
and he's even becoming uh
something of a crush for many people
yeah people online are falling in love
with him
i'm not gonna lie and those people
include me
my tinder profile now lists me as a
homosexual a cuomo sexual they're all
sorts of
social media influencers just writing
these these odes these these romantic
ballads to andrew cuomo
and what was the reality the reality was
he was the maybe the worst governor in
the country in terms of his handling of
kovid he was one of the worst governors
in in the country in terms of his
handling of his staff notably his female
staff everything we were told about this
guy
totally competent on kovit a hero new
york tough he was a he's a feminist he
stands up for women
all of it turned out to be a lie and we
were told this
by the entertainment establishment guys
like trevor noah we're told this by the
news media establishment for goodness
sakes cuomo's brother hosted a show on
cnn i was gonna say it's a major show on
cnn but no show is a major show on cnn
still it was one of their bigger shows
and he was bringing on andrew cuomo to
to joke about how how he didn't call his
mother enough and then they yucked it up
a little bit and he and he went into his
earnest voice and fredo said andre
you're doing a wonderful job brother i'm
so and he wasn't none of this was true
it was all a lie and now people
wonder why
none of us trust the media establishment
the scientific establishment the
political establishment
this sort of thing is not just on the
fringes it's not just people like trevor
noah
this sort of thing went all the way up
to the top
joe biden
was lauding andrew cuomo during the
entirety of 2020 while joe biden was
running for president and now that joe
biden is the president even after this
wild scandal the nursing home and the
sex stuff
joe biden is still praising
andrew cuomo it makes me want to have
some relief and when i want relief do
you know where i turn i turn to relief
band relief band is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wrist band that has
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more
i know what you're here you're hearing
okay there's some band and it's gonna
what is this i don't know maybe i tried
one of these in the past i paid like 10
bucks for it
no
this is a hundred percent drug free it's
non-drowsy it provides all-natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed
the way it works is it stimulates a
nerve in the wrist that travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
this stuff was developed for use in
hospitals this one works it is number
one fda cleared go get it now as the
world's opening back up do not let the
fear of nausea keep you on the sidelines
right now relief ban has an exclusive
offer just for michael now show
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code knowledge you'll receive
20 off plus free shipping and no
questions asked for a 30-day money-back
guarantee that is
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com
use promo code knowles for 20 off plus
free shipping
even after
the announcement of the resignation even
after the attorney general report
showing that andrew cuomo got very grab
happy even after the doj investigation
of andrew cuomo
joe biden says as governor
cuomo did a hell of a job
one of the democrats
through the years that you spoke with
about infrastructure the most
was andrew cuom who is resigning well
now he's resigning today you had
traveled new york with him when you were
vice president to the launch of the
reconstruction of laguardia he was
someone who supported your campaign
early on no you calling him to resign no
you condemned the alleged behavior but
you're someone who spends a lot of time
with mayors and governors
how would you assess
his ten and a half years
as governor of the state
in terms of his personal behavior or
what he's done as a governor
but he's done a hell of a job
thought he's done a hell of a job
and uh
i mean both on everything from
access to voting to infrastructure the
whole range of things
that's why it's so sad
i have to say that on one point i do
agree with joe biden here andrew cuomo
did a hell of a job as governor
emphasis here of course is on the word
hell i was a constituent of andrew
cuomo's i have met andrew cuomo on
multiple occasions
i'm a native new yorker
i i was andrew cuomo's waiter once at a
restaurant when i was working at a
restaurant high school i ran into andrew
cuomo during hurricane sandy actually
because my pals and i walked out with
cigars during the hurricane literally
bumped into
governor governor cuomo then
he wasn't the worst governor in the
history of new york but he was pretty
bad he he pushed for an abortion law
that would legalize abortion up until
the moment of birth
a
huge liberalization of abortion laws and
when it wasn't enough just that he did
that he then celebrated that by lighting
up the freedom tower in pink
to celebrate this wonderful thing that
he was going to kill a lot more little
baby girls isn't that wonderful isn't
that a win for women
this guy an absolute knuckle dragging
moral idiot
scandal-ridden corrupt
did a hell of a job and
still the liberal establishment even as
they show him the curtains even as they
say buddy time to get off the stage
even still they defend him they are
going softer right now on andrew cuomo
one of the worst if not the worst
governor in the country
than they are on ron desantis the best
governor in the country not just because
he never winked at his secretary not
just because he never got grab happy
with the staff but because he did better
on coronavirus than any other governor
in the country and he pursued the
opposite policies than we saw from
certainly from andrew cuomo or from
gavin newsom or anyone else and yet
still
cuomo gets the pat on the head and
desantis does not actually the federal
government appears to be actively lying
about governor desantis's record
the cdc
is reporting you know the cdc that
agency with so much credibility after
the last 18 months the cdc is reporting
that there were 28 317 new cases of the
coronavirus in florida on sunday
this would mark
the most confirmed infections in one day
in the state since the beginning of the
15 days to slow the spread 15 days that
has turned into a year and a half
now notice here that the number is on
new cases
the reason that it's on new cases rather
than new hospitalizations or new deaths
from coronavirus is because those
numbers the numbers that actually matter
have plummeted basically to nothing
whereas new cases
what does that matter especially when so
many people are vaccinated and allegedly
the vaccine
causes you know one to be protected from
the severest symptoms when the death
rate is very very low
they have to move on to keep everybody
in fear to keep everybody continuing to
comply with their draconian measures
but even that turns out to be a lie
because the florida department of health
just came out
and
says that actually there were only 15
319 cases on sunday and that the three
day average is 18 795 that's 10 000
cases fewer than
and more than in the case of sunday more
than ten thousand cases fewer than the
cdc
is noting do you think is this just an
error whoopsie daisy another clerical
error
or is this part of a broader pattern
of lies and obfuscation
and deception and misleading to keep us
all locked up forever so it was the 15
days to first of all it was to flatten
the curve then it was 15 days to slow
the spread then it was to find a cure
then it was to get everybody vaccinated
now it is to stop the delta and then
it's going to be to stop the lambda
they're already talking about the lambda
and the sigma and the phi beta kappa
and the
sigap and the delta kappa epsilon it's
going to go on forever
and ever and ever unless we stop it
unless now some people are standing up
to stop it there is actually
some good news in politics and you know
there's so rarely good news these days
for conservatives but there is some
potential good news
namely
gavin newsom
may end up being recalled gavin newsom
governor bateman mussolini over there in
my former state of california
is facing the election of his life
this was even as of a couple of weeks
ago the voters were basically evenly
split
on on the recall effort don't forget
first there's going to be a vote of
whether or not to recall gavin newsom or
not that's just a yes or no vote and
then if he is recalled the the candidate
with the most votes will be the next
governor of california
so you'll remember a couple weeks ago
there was a poll out said it was about
evenly split
you haven't heard very many poll numbers
since then
one wonders if that is in part because
the numbers are getting even worse for
gavin newsom and you know the democrats
are going to try to pull a lot of
shenanigans in terms of voter fraud
california is one of the worst states
because they have so few election
integrity measures they have motor voter
laws you just get signed up to vote when
you're at the dmv this opens the door to
lots of illegal aliens for instance
being registered to vote and obviously
california is a huge problem with
illegal aliens it's not a problem for
the democrats it's actually part of the
strategy california's got a big problem
with ballot harvesting and now
california has this problem with
widespread mail-in ballots so it's not
even enough just to register to vote in
another state
it may even be the case in california
and i've heard this from
multiple of my co-workers even
that
they will still have ballots mailed to
their homes even after they've moved out
of california so what's going to happen
to those ballots are they secure no
obviously not and their ballot drop off
so you don't even need to prove who you
are so
the democrats i think are counting on
all of these shenanigans to still
maintain control of the state
but if
they can't do it if gavin newsom does
get recalled
larry elder may end up being the
governor of california larry elder many
of you know
a very well-known conservative radio
host he's been on lots of tv shows he's
been on my show he's i've been on his
show he's
pretty conservative i i you know he's a
little bit libertarian he's a little
more libertarian certainly than i am i
think
probably attila the hun is more
libertarian than i am but but larry
elder is a very strong candidate and he
would be a huge huge improvement over
gavin newsom and right now he is way out
raising he is way out polling the other
gop candidates so the other candidates
as you'll recall are kevin faulconer he
was down in san diego uh john cox who
lost pretty badly to gavin newsom last
time and caitlin caitlyn jenner bruce
jenner is running he says he has no
loyalty to trump or to the republican
party and his real loyalty is only to
lgbt with an emphasis on the t so not
the greatest republican candidate
probably ever but it doesn't really
matter because no matter how the the
votes would be divvied up
the top guy is going to become the
governor
this is why i think the california gop
is choosing not to endorse in this race
is
probably not the worst thing in the
world so of the of the candidates here
you got you know larry elder assemblyman
kevin kylie and then kevin faulconer a
few other people
uh this is a big help to kevin faulconer
for instance who is not polling very
well he's not raising a lot of money um
but i but i do think it was the right
decision for the california gop not to
endorse a candidate here because
the argument from the california gop is
if they endorse a candidate then it's
going to turn off the voters who
otherwise would show up to endorse or to
vote against gavin newsom so it it
really doesn't matter it's not as though
the recall candidate has to get more
than 50 of the vote they just need to be
the top the top person
so if i were gavin newsom i would be
very
very nervous right now and you can see
it there are actually some clips of him
going going around we will get them on
the show in the next few days of him
talking to reporters where he's just
losing it
he's really totally falling into his
sort of american psycho you know slicked
back hair you're starting to see a crack
to this otherwise very well put together
facade and there's other good news by
the way for 2022 and 2024 there are some
republican candidates out there who are
they're ditching the old stale slogans
of the last 15 20 years of republican
politics which have just represented
loss after loss after loss you saw this
begin to happen with donald trump then
you you see this with some other
candidates you've got jd vance who is
the author of hillbilly elegy he's
running in ohio he's really
contradicting the gop's agenda on for
instance showing for big corporations
that hate our guts now you've got a
candidate blake masters in arizona
running for senate who's explicitly
calling out not just critical race
theory but what it represents which is
anti-white racism you can hear more
about that and everything else with your
ray cons i really need to personally
thank raikon i seriously need to
personally thank raycon right now not
just because it's a wonderful product
it's got lots of cool colorways it fits
in your ear way better than those other
guys that you don't have little stems
sticking out so you look like a bug
i
was just on a flight i was on a not
eight and a half hour flight with my
six-month-old baby
and when when the when the cries get a
little bit too much
i i could just pop in my earbuds oh my
gosh it was bliss it was absolutely
wonderful i would strongly recommend you
get a pair of rakons today they've got
32-hour battery life so you can listen
to what you want when you want for a
really long time they start at half the
price of the other premium audio brands
they got a 45 day happiness guarantee
you really can't lose and they are
superior to the other products on the
market create your own soundtrack with
raycon right now my listeners get 15 off
their raycon order at buyracon.com
knowles that's byracon.com knowles to
save 15 percent off of raycon says
byracon.com
knowles you can order ben's new book the
authoritarian moment
it's available at amazon barnes and
noble any other major bookseller it's a
great book to buy
immediately after you buy my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds i would recommend that is the the
proper order to buy those books in but i
do recommend you get ben's book because
it will be my campaign slogan in a few
years also if you sign up now as a daily
wire member with code vip you will get
25 off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip for two to the daily wire
studios in nashville you'll see candace
live not only will you meet candace
herself but you'll be getting an inside
look at her studio and front row seats
to watch her show live so that is
dailywire.com
subscribe with code vip 25 off so you
can automatically be entered to win a
vip experience or if you're already an
all access member you can now purchase
tickets for her show in nashville
tennessee head on over to dailywire.com
tickets today to pick up yours we'll be
right back with a lot more
you've heard a lot about critical race
theory over the past few weeks in
critical race theory is this
ridiculous
academic movement that derives from the
school of western marxists and critical
theory and it questions not not just the
idea that we all ought to be treated
fairly and equally but it questions
whether or not there is even
objective reality itself objective truth
itself or if it's all a social
construction of the white supremacist
patriarchal this that and the other
thing
a lot of what it comes down to though is
simpler than that it's kind of why i
opened the show with chet hanks
because chet hanks might talk a little
bit rough but he's
saying i think what a lot of people feel
when we talk about critical race theory
very often what we're just talking about
is
people being made to feel bad for being
white people being made to feel bad for
the color of their skin being told that
if you have this color skin you're good
and if you have this color skin you're
bad and you can never fix it and it's
you're irredeemable and deplorable and
all the other words that we've heard
conservatives referred to over the years
and by the way even if you're black but
you support conservatives you are
laboring under a false consciousness
you're a mental slave you are you are
upholding the white supremacy and the
patriarchy
there's one candidate in arizona who's
calling it out he's saying you know this
is anti-white racism it's no better than
any other kind of racism and we've got
to get rid of it that man's name
blake masters in arizona where do these
crazy ideas come from how could you
possibly believe this stuff
well unfortunately it all goes back to
the schools
too much of schooling in america
has become a machine to uproot common
sense
and to replace it with something much
more sinister
you've heard of critical race theory i
assume at this point right conservatives
are up in arms about it and rightfully
so
it sounds academic
it sounds fancy it's not
all it does is teach kids to identify in
racial terms right you are good or bad
depending on what you look like
at this point it is straight up
anti-white racism i don't think we're
allowed to say that
but let's call it what it is it is toxic
and it does not belong in our schools
i love it i like how plainly he's
speaking
people are going to call him and jd
vance and other people anti-intellectual
they're rubes they're idiots they're
uneducated
first of all these are extremely
intelligent well-educated people who've
had very successful careers who have but
what they're doing that is unforgivable
is they are contradicting the dominant
narrative so if you say that a man can
be a woman and a baby's not a baby
you're a genius you're educated you're
smart you use all this smart jargon if
you say that it's wrong to make people
feel bad for for being white or any
other race then you're you're an idiot
and you're dumb and i think the
candidates who are going to be most
exciting the candidates who are going to
be most successful
in in the future are going to be the
ones who eschew this sort of silly
jargon and all the platitudes uh that
that are typical of the last couple of
decades of politics
and they just get right to the heart of
the issue what he said there is very
telling he said i'm not sure if we're
allowed to say that
and that's going to be a big issue too
because who determines what we are
allowed to say and what we are not
allowed to say
is not just we the people it's not just
the standards that we have in our
society it's not just the taboos that we
choose to live under
it's a handful of billionaire oligarchs
in silicon valley led by hipster
rasputin jack dorsey who you know he's
got the smallest platform but it's got a
lot of influence because of all of the
journalists that are on it
and it's mark zuckerberg and it's sundar
pichai at google
and they are pushing this stuff
they are actively promoting this and
they are actively suppressing
other voices like rand paul before we
get to rand paul i just want to i just
want to point out
how radical this crt stuff really is
there's a princeton course right now it
just it just went princeton university
one of the most
elite
prestigious universities in the country
they're featuring a course on black
lives matter
now the seminar will trace the
historical roots of the black lives
matter social movement in the united
states and comparative global contexts
okay now right there if if that's all
the course did i wouldn't have that much
of a problem with it blm is an important
movement yeah um it has an interesting
intellectual history i actually talk
about it at some length in my recent
book speechless
so sure let's explore i'm all about
exploring all of these things and
learning about what they mean but that's
not what the course is doing
the course is pushing the blm agenda
the movement and the course are
committed to
resisting unveiling and undoing
histories of state-sanctioned violence
against black and brown bodies i guess
it's not violence against their souls
it's just just their bodies that's the
new that's the leftist jargon the course
seeks to document the forms of
dispossession that black americans face
and offers a critical examination of the
prison industrial complex police
brutality urban poverty and white
supremacy in the united states so the
course is taking the position of black
lives matter and then indoctrinating
students into its outrageous
anti-american marxist incorrect views
the the course will feature writings
from angela davis angela davis is a
communist terrorist who's associated
with the kidnapping of a federal judge
the issue is not
with the with the reading the issue is
not with the books or the subject matter
it's with the perspective
okay and i think this shows the weakness
of what has become a kind of
quote-unquote conservative position over
the last decade which is we will often
say you know that we're defenders of
academic freedom meaning you can teach
whatever you want in the classroom
even though really that only ever seems
to redown to the benefit of the left or
the idea that we don't want to
indoctrinate students we want to educate
students and that the teachers need to
be totally neutral education cannot be
totally neutral
you need to t in order to teach anything
you need to teach that some things are
true and other things are false some
things are good and other things are bad
and some things are right and other
things are wrong so you actually do need
to take a stand william f buckley jr
launched the conservative the modern
conservative movement with a book called
god and man at yale that made fun of
this ridiculous idea of neutrality that
actually said we need to take a stand on
some of these issues
if we're going to teach a course on blm
we are going to have to have some
perspective on it either that it's a
terrible no-good rotten organization or
that it's not so great but it comes here
the reasons that it's developed or that
it's a good organization and it's really
great and it's all of its claims are
true but you are going to have to take
some
perspective on it and i think the reason
conservatives lose is because we don't
recognize that and the left recognizes
it pretty well
but it is having effects it's when
things
are
echoing around the halls of princeton or
harvard or yale or hollywood studios or
the halls of government or any of these
elite institutions they reverberate out
into the broader world so recently
you've just seen simone biles
who is not particularly educated though
she is uh
apparently a very accomplished athlete
i've never watched her i didn't know who
she was until two weeks ago i don't
really watch the olympics not my cup of
tea but i've been told she's a good
athlete
and i
really don't have any opinion about her
athletics i have an opinion about how
she doesn't care enough about her
country to recognize that appearing at
the olympics is not just about her it's
about representing america
and
who
has to recognize that she is there not
just for herself but for the broader
community well simone biles proved me
right
because she just came out as very
pro-abortion
simone biles just wrote quote i already
know that this is going to start the
biggest argument and may even lose
followers but
i'm very much pro-choice your body your
choice also for everyone going to say
put it up for adoption it's not that
easy and coming from someone who is in
the foster care system trust me the
foster care system is broken and it's
tough especially on the kids and young
adults who age out and adoption is
expensive i'm just saying
so i want to be
i want to be as charitable to simone
biles as i can
my impulse is to not be charitable to
simone viles but i want i actually do
want to be charitable to her here she
has heard all of this stuff
from every elite institution in the
country for her entire life okay and she
did come from tough circumstances her
parents were apparently
not uh particularly supportive she was
in the foster care system though she
actually did get out of the foster care
system pretty quickly she was there
until about the age of three and then
her grandfather found out about this and
started to take care of her a little bit
and he officially adopted her at the age
of six and then obviously you know she's
had this great great athletic career
so the one of the problems with her
argument is she's saying yeah look i
overcame this thing
but other people shouldn't have that
opportunity
yeah i you know i underwent some amount
of suffering
and that's fine by me and obviously i'm
one of the most celebrated athletes in
the world now but other people it's
going to be too tough for them so just
kill them just kill them in the womb
well yeah i guess you could you could
just put the baby up for adoption but
you know adoption is expensive first of
all i don't even know what that means
there are 32 couples for every baby that
is
32 couples who want to adopt for every
one baby who was put up for adoption in
the united states so i guess it's
expensive in the sense that you've gotta
continue to you know make sure you go to
doctors and eat right
while you're pregnant but that's not not
a huge expense it's an inconvenience but
the alternative is killing the baby
what
this woman's opinions are
derived from a broader culture i don't
think it derives from a deep study of
abortion i don't think it derives from a
deep study of how of gestation and how
babies are made or biology or philosophy
or theology it derives from the culture
and so i think a lot of people are going
to have that opinion you hear this a lot
actually oh you know foster care system
is bad oh there's so many kids who are
unwanted oh there was an argument made
in freakonomics that actually you know
these kids because they're in bad
circumstances they'll go on and commit
crime and so you know you don't want to
have crime so let's just kill them in
the womb these are hideous vile ugly
arguments but because they're protected
by the culture they go on and on
and on and so it's incumbent upon us to
be able to get into those institutions
wield that political power and then
and then reshape them now speaking of
dubious medical advice here's where we
get to who really controls
the speech dr fauci comes out the
esteemed dr fauci high pontiff of
progressivism peace be upon him
dr fauci comes out and says
even after we've heard that there won't
be vaccine mandates and we shouldn't
have vaccine mandates
he now thinks that vaccine mandates are
good at least for teachers
dr fauci do you agree with randy
weingarten the head of the largest
teachers union in the country who came
out yesterday and said yes teachers
should be vaccinated inside schools do
you think they should be mandated to be
vaccinated
yeah i'm going to upset some people on
this but i think we should i mean we are
in a critical situation now we've had
615
000 plus deaths and we are in a major
surge now as we're going into the fall
into the school season this is very
serious business you would wish that
people would see why it's so important
to get vaccinated but you're not going
to get mandates centrally from the
federal government but when you're
talking about local mandates mandates
for schools for teachers for
universities for colleges i'm sorry i i
mean i know people must like to have
their individual freedom and not be told
to do something but i think we're in
such a serious situation now that under
certain circumstances mandates should be
done
you can hear the contempt and the
disdain just dribbling out of his mouth
look i understand that all you filthy
disgusting pros like your freedom
and your liberty
but
that's all well and good unless you
contradict good old dr fauci
then you're gonna get in line she now
what he's doing here i think is a little
bit of a misdirection by the way
it's a little bit of a straw man yes we
would like our liberty not just in the
sort of narrow sense of individual
liberty not to have a mask or shoot up
something into our arm that we don't
want
but the political liberty to make those
decisions why is this unelected
bureaucrat who's been serving for what
like five presidents at this point
presidents come and go fauci remains why
is this guy making all these decisions
why don't we have a say in this
self-government and even beyond that
even beyond the question of the
political liberty is the question of
prudence and credibility
why can we not say hey look actually for
huge numbers of people the virus is not
particularly lethal for some people
perhaps it is but for others it's not
and this drug has not been approved by
the fda it's got an emergency youth
authorization but it doesn't have a full
approval so using our faculties of
judgment we just don't think that a
mandate why are you not allowed to say
that because it contradicts the whims of
dr fauci and that guy has got all the
power
but you can't question dr fauci
you cannot question dr fauci or the
liberal establishment or any of these
other elite institutions
even if you are a medical doctor
even if you are a medical doctor who is
a united states senator
dr rand paul dr senator rand paul
posted a video
in which he questioned the efficacy and
the safety of masks
as some people have i no i would never
do that you hear that youtube i would
never do that but some people have done
that over the past year and a half
including dr senator rand paul
and some punk at youtube who's never
appeared on a ballot
decided to delete the video
from
the big tech platforms
which is the public square
these big tech guys even admit that it's
the public square now so they delete the
rand paul video so then rand paul puts
up a video
about how his video about the masks was
deleted
and they deleted that video too we
managed to get a clip of it here he is
censorship by youtube is very dangerous
as it stifles debate and promotes group
think where the truth is defined by
people with a political agenda youtube
said the video violated their policy
because of my comments on masks and that
they don't allow videos that contradict
government's guidance on kovid
youtube may be a private entity but
they're acting like an arm of the
government censoring those who present
an alternative view to the science
deniers in washington
people like dr fauci who have lied to
the american people time and time again
about masks so youtube says that the
reason they took down to see if you can
figure out the flaw in youtube's
reasoning youtube says that the reason
they took down
senator rand paul's video about the
masks
is because it contradicted
the official narrative of the government
on masks
you ca did you catch the little fl and
they'll go further they'll say the
government's line on masks derives from
the
scientists so that's why they had to
take down doctor
senator
rand paul what youtube is acknowledging
is something that is becoming clearer
and clearer every day
which is that the government is not the
us senate the government is not the us
house of representatives the government
is not even the president of the united
states
the government is
the blob
the government is the liberal
establishment the sort of permanent
state the bureaucracy the administrative
agencies the fouchies
in concert with
the big tech platforms and in concert
with the media and in concert with the
educational institutions
that's why
donald trump would be kicked off of
twitter and facebook and youtube and
every other big social media platform
that's why these handful of oligarchs
are able to censor the duly elected
sitting president of the united states
boot him out of the public square
because the president is not the
government and nor
nor the senators
you cannot
question that sort of thing
don't forget i actually had had
forgotten this until just last night
rand paul is not the only person who's
questioned the efficacy and the safety
of the vaccines or the efficacy and the
safety or of the masks rather i suppose
in this case
joe biden and kamala harris both
questioned the efficacy and the safety
of the vaccines they were asked last
year will you get the vaccine
and they said well i'm not so sure and
trumpy i don't know i'm a little
skeptical of trump here and i don't know
if i would be willing to take a trump
they did it they did the same thing that
that the conservatives are now being
de-platformed and ostracized for and
cast into outer darkness
but when they do it it doesn't matter
and when you do it it does matter
because this is not about a principle
and it's not about a rule it's not about
the rule of law in our constitutional
republic it's about the whims and the
caprices of
the power mad
bureaucrats and establishmentarians who
have
all of the power
barack obama's birthday party
that's that's how we opened up the show
with that comment you say you know my
opinion on masks is that i'm still
celebrating barack obama's birthday
party
the people who flew to barack obama's
birthday party i think to to a man
are deeply concerned about climate
change they talk climate change is the
greatest threat the sun monster is going
to kill us all we just had there was the
code red from the united nations
intergovernmental panel on climate
change just a few days ago
and yet
so many of them flew private jets to the
party according to the martha's vineyard
gazette
traffic was very increased due to the
party airport manager jeffrey friedman
says
it very nearly put us beyond our
capacity both for fuel and for parking
spacing so if a republican flies a
private jet that's a big problem if a
democrat flies a private jet not a
problem at all if a republican questions
the masks it's a very big problem you've
got to be ostracized if a democrat
questions the masks that's that's
speaking truth to power that's wonderful
same thing goes for the vaccines
republican questions that he's a kook
threat to public health murderer if a
democrat questions the vaccines he's
going to get elected president and or
elected vice president or both
this is the lack of credibility you want
to talk about disbelief
you may have seen this story well mate
you probably didn't see this story
because you're you're an intelligent
person who doesn't watch cnn all the
time but cnn viewers may have may have
heard this story a single mother of
three
faced eviction
unless
the the eviction moratorium
could could have gone back into effect
and been extended and her name was dasha
kelly and cnn sent a reporter nick watt
to kelly's home they did a tour they
promoted kelly's gofundme page the
single mother of three
representative cory bush
pushed this story from seeing the single
mother of three unless the democrat
policy is extended
it was just all a lie
the woman
is not a single mother of three
she's not single
she's not a mother of anybody it turns
out
she's dating a guy
who has three kids with another woman
she doesn't even live with the guy
and i guess she knows the kids but the
kids don't live with her it was all
completely made up
it was a fiction
to push a narrative and cnn will not
face any
consequences from this
and probably this woman won't face any
she'll probably just walk away with the
money
and
nobody will and it won't matter and we
can expose the lies and they'll still
have the power and they'll still have
the power people people are getting sick
of it i think
people people want to push back against
that people don't like it but when will
we be able to grab the power when will
we be able to wield that power because
right now a handful of people are
exercising all of that here in the
united states
and they're trying to make it harder and
harder to oust them from office time
maybe running out to do so
it's time for the chet hanks's of the
world
to continue to speak up it's time to
speak in plain language about the rife
the rank corruption all around us i'm
michael knowles it's the michael miller
show i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode new york governor andrew
cuomo resigns chicago police turn their
backs on the mayor and the u.s has a
record 10.1 million job openings join us
and get the facts first on the news you
need to know with our show morningwire
[Music]